[Music]
former new york governor andrew cuomo
will not face criminal charges related
to claims from a former staffer that he
groped her the albany county district
attorney said yesterday that he found
cuomo's accuser her name is brittany
comisso cooperative and her allegations
were credible but he said there was not
enough evidence to
prove her allegations in court cuomo
stepped down as governor back in august
after several women publicly accused him
of sexual misconduct erika duncan has
been following this story for months and
joins us now with the latest eureka good
morning to you
[Music]
good morning to you gail this was the
third district attorney's office to stop
pursuing sexual misconduct charges
against the former governor last night
brittany camiso told me she's simply
frustrated in fact she believes that
this is part of the reason why many
victims don't come forward
in my mind
i've never crossed the line with anyone
former new york governor andrew cuomo
was expected to appear in court this
friday to face a misdemeanor charge but
the albany county district attorney's
office announced it will not prosecute
the case related to allegations from his
former executive assistant brittany
comisso
last summer the new york state attorney
general's office released a report that
concluded cuomo sexually harassed
multiple women several district
attorneys launched investigations legal
experts believed commisso's allegations
were the most likely to result in
charges
he
walked over shut the door
so hard came back to me
and that's when he put his hand up my
blouse and cupped my breast over my bra
in an exclusive interview last august
camiso said cuomo groped her at the
governor's mansion in 2020. why did you
file that criminal complaint with the
sheriff's office it was the right thing
to do the governor needs to be held
accountable
but albany county district attorney
david soares says his office cannot
prove that while he remains deeply
troubled by allegations like commissos
after reviewing the evidence his office
concluded that we cannot meet our burden
at trial
cbs news legal analyst ricky clemen says
this might not be over because the
burden of proof in a civil case is much
different than a criminal one i have no
doubt that brittany commission's
attorney will bring a civil lawsuit
for the civil penalty
for sexual assault
and in that case the justice that the
law gives you is money
and commisso's attorney in fact did say
that his client will continue to seek
justice through civil action it's
important to note the former governor
andrew cuomo always maintained that he
did not partake in any sexual misconduct
we did reach out to his attorney she had
no comment tony
all right thank you very much